I was lucky enough in the end of my graduate career
to get to go to my first scientific meeting.
And so I was sitting in the audience and most of the talks were so far over my head,
I couldn't understand them,
and I thought,
you know,
maybe I don't even like science because I was sort of bored out of my mind.
And then this man got up, who will become my postdoc advisor,
and his name was Michael Silverman,
and he got up and he gave this talk about a glow in the dark bacterium. That
what had been discovered was that the bacteria had the special property that it
makes bioluminescence,
so glows in the dark.
And what had been shown by Woody Hastings is that the bacterium didn't glow and then when
it reached a certain cell number,
all the bacteria turned on light together.
Mike Silverman said,
look,
you could make mutants and just turn the lights off in the room and find bacteria
that either make light when they shouldn't or don't make light when they should.
And by tracking that bioluminescence behavior,
you could find the genes and find the components.
And I thought,
surely I'm smart enough to turn the lights off in the room and figure out which of these cells are dark and
bright.
And literally he made it sound so easy.
And he made it sound so amazing that these bacteria could work in a group that I
literally ran up to the podium and was just hanging off the podium and said,
"you have to let me be your post doc."
So when I went to Mike Silverman's lab as a postdoc,
he had found the gene and the enzyme that makes the signal
molecule,
and he had found the receptor for the signal molecule,
and he had found the genes that make light.
And so it was simple.
There was an enzyme that made the signal molecule,
which we call an autoinducer,
there was a receptor for the autoinducer,
and when the molecule builds up,
the receptor binds it and then together that complex turns on light.
Silverman and found that, that's the story I heard at this famous, to me,
seminar that he gave.
And so what we wondered was,
could there be more to it?
And so I went there to find out if there was more to it,
like were there more than just these two components an autoinducer and a
receptor.
And so my project was to work in a new
bioluminescent bacterium,
and what I wanted to do was to mutate the genes for the
known components, that he had already found, and see if there was more.
What I was trying to do was to mutate the bacterial chromosome and look for
bacteria that were dark.
So usually when they're talking, quorum sensing is happening,
they make light.
I was going to mutate them and look for dark mutants, bacteria that made no light,
figuring if I got a mutation in the gene that made the autoinducer or
the gene that made the receptor, since one of those would be gone,
you know would be mutated,
then the bacteria wouldn't make light.
And so I did that experiment again and again and again.
And the only mutations I got were in the actual genes
for the luciferase,
the enzymes that made light. I never got the molecule and I never got the
receptor,
and that didn't make sense because I knew there had to be those genes.
So I was trained as a biochemist and this was genetics,
and I'd never had a genetics class.
And so I had a big
crisis of confidence.
I was doing these genetic experiments,
and Mike Silverman,
you know,
was a great geneticist,
and he had taught me this genetics I was supposed to like, very rapidly just dispense with the
known genes and move on to something more interesting.
And I remember thinking like,
I'm just not getting this genetics because I could never get the mutants that I
was tasked to get.
And then one day,
I actually just,
you know,
sat down at my desk after I got the same result again,
which was mutations in luciferase, but no receptor,
no autoinducer genes,
and I thought,
I actually finally just stopped doing and sat down and
said,
why don't you think about it and thought to myself like,
how could you get that result? And
literally in that moment, and it took a long time to get to that moment,
I thought up the actual answer,
which was,
if there were multiple autoinducers and multiple receptors,
and you inactivated one and another system still worked,
this experiment could never work.
An experiment that I had been doing for,
like,
fifty hours a week for a year,
right?
And so I didn't know it was right at the time,
but it actually gave me at least another way to think about it,
and I could try a different strategy.
And like, when I think back to that time,
I don't understand why it took me so long to come to that idea,
right?
But it does.
It's just the process where you're doing these things with your hands and your brain and
information is rattling around in your head and you're kind of in this mess of it
and you can't see your way through.
And then all of a sudden,
like in an unpredictable way,
which is something I love about science,
you have these moments of clarity.
And I don't know where they come from,
and I don't know why it was that day and not later or not earlier,
but it was that day.
And the instant I thought of that idea,
I literally brought a garbage can over and I dumped all my Petri plates into it,
cleared off my bench, and started a new strategy,
which ended up to work.
I thought,
okay,
if these bacteria really do make multiple autoinducers, multiple receptors,
how would I find the genes for them?
And I thought,
okay,
if I knock out one autoinducer and one receptor, but there's another one working,
the bacteria won't be dark,
but maybe they won't be wild type,
right?
Maybe they'll be dim.
They'll make less light because they're kind of their kind of hobbled. You knock out one system,
the other one's working,
but two are better.
And so that I realized, that I had during the original
nonworking strategy, there had been on all these
Petri plates where I was looking for dark mutants,
there had been lots of mutants that were dim, that made not zero light,
but not bright light.
I had thrown all of those in the garbage can because they didn't fit my
original idea.
And so I had a hint, this is going to work,
right?
And so I just went back and I collected, I made more mutants,
and I collected up all the dim mutants.
And when I sequenced the mutations in those
genes,
it was very clear there were genes for multiple autoinducers and multiple
receptors.
And if you knock them all out together,
then the bacteria had a real problem making bioluminescence.
But only if you,
you know,
made them so they couldn't speak either of their languages.
That was a really fun time,
sort of.
So before me, there was one molecule; that's Mike Silverman's work and Woody Hastings
before him.
Then with me,
at that moment,
there were two molecules.
And so that did two things.
It said, we actually don't know the number of molecules, right?
Finding the second one meant it's not one,
but it didn't mean it was over.
So that opened up horizons,
that there could be many molecules involved. That ended up being true much
later.
And the other thing that was really interesting,
in my view about that finding, was that that made
bacteria very much like eukaryotes.
So we know that higher organisms, you know, take in all kinds of pieces of
sensory information,
you know,
they decode it,
they integrate it, and they behave based on many stimuli around them.
And the finding of the two molecules meant that could be true in a bacterium
as well,
right?
And so maybe they're not so different from higher organisms in the
sense of this ability to be computer-like and to take in
bits of information, right, and to process it, and to
have very sophisticated behaviors based on very sophisticated inputs.
That ended up being true too.
And so one kind of eureka moment is just the new idea and I like that because then you're
feeling very frustrated and all of a sudden, you have a horizon.
I love those eureka moments.
Other of the eureka moments which are really fun, is you're on that path
and you find the answer, like when we find a gene or we find a
molecule,
right?
And that kind of eureka moment is the "I got it."
Not the "I have the idea," but, "I got the
answer." And that eureka moment is also wonderful,
but it's always followed by,
well,
why is it that, and then you're on to your next path,
right,
which I think is fun.
So you're never done,
and I think that's a lot of fun.